اليوم الث للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
وبعد مرور شهرين من بدء العمليه البريه
تطورات متلاحقه من شمال الى جنوب قطاع غزه
سنبدا من المنطقه
الجنوبيه نظرا لسرعه التطورات وكثافه
الاحداث في الساعات الاخيره في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه تحديدا نحن الان
مازلنا نتحدث عن المعركه الكبرى او القتال
الاكثر ضراوه بحسب الوصف الاسرائيلي حول
مدينه خان يونس وفي بعض الاحياء داخل
مدينه خان يونس الجيش الاسرائيلي بطبيعه
الحال يهاجم المدينه من اكثر من محور
وهناك كثافه ناريه كثيره واشتباكات عنيفه
قبل قليل كتائب القسام قالت انها استهدفت
مجموعه من الاليات في المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه ل مدينه خانيونس ايضا ك كان
هناك تفجير لمجموعه من الجنود نفذتها
سرايا القدس في منطقه عبسا وفي منطقه
خزاعه ايضا هناك استهداف لاليه عسكريه
ومجمل الاليات التي دمرت منذ صباح هذا
اليوم في المنطقه الجنوبيه للقطاع فاقت
عشر اليات ما بين دبابه وناقله جند هناك
استهداف ايضا لنقله جند ويقول قسام انه
اوقع خسائر ما بين قتيل وجريح هذه
التطورات كان سبقها اعلان اسرائيل انها
دفعت بلواء جديد الى داخل المنطقه
الجنوبيه في خان يونس يقاتل خمسه الويه من
الجيش الاسرائيلي اخرهم قبل اربعه ايام
انضم الى العمليات القتاليه لواء كفير
الذي يوصف بانه من اكبر الويه المشاه لديه
قطع او لديه ك كتائب مدرعات وعمليات خاصه
الاعلان عن ادخال اليوم لواء سادس الى هذه
المنطقه يعطينا فكره عن حجم العمليات
وايضا حجم الخسائر لانه هذه المنطقه في
قطاع غزه هي الاكثر عرضا من من الشمال الى
الجنوب بال عرضا في الخط العرضي هي مساحه
ممتده وبالتالي في حال على سبيل المثال
ارادت اسرائيل ان تبدل الوحدات سيكون
عليها ان تقطع مسافه طويله من خانيونس الى
الحدود مع غلاف غزه في هذه التطورات ايضا
كانت وسط وسط القطاع تطورات متلاحقه
استهدافات وقتال بالتحديد عند المنطقه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه وهناك استهدافات ايضا
لكتائب القسام وسرايا القدس للجيش
الاسرائيلي وايقاع خسائر وفي الشمال هناك
بعض الاشتباكات وهناك حرك
اسرائيليه يمكن ان نقول بانها مرتبكه من
الناحيه العسكريه تتحرك بعض القطاعات ولكن
لا يبدو واضحا ما اذا كانت تنسحب تبدل
الجنود او تعيد التموضع وسيله هذه ابرز
مجريات الميدان وبالتاكيد معك واللواء
دويري سنفهم السياقات افضل